and we turn to an incredible story of
recovery you may remember zionna pitbull
left for dead months ago
this is what he looked like at the time
and denise is with his foster parent to
speak about his journey back to health
denise
we are so happy now to give you an
update on zion so many of you reached
out to us after we shared his story of
being abandoned and extremely skinny
after being adopted from a local shelter
but we can't really fill in the gaps
until now so with us right now is alex
ortega who is a dog trainer but also you
have been the foster parent for zion for
a couple of months
he really looks so thin his ribs were
showing how is he doing because he looks
great now his coat looks amazing
he's doing really well
the first thing we had to do is kind of
help get the weight back on him
but at the same time
limit his exercise
just because we want to make sure he
maintains that weight
he gets along great with my 140 pound
dog i have at home
and you know gets along great with my
son and your son's just two years old
he's two years old yeah he's he's crazy
his name's archie and
he's uh he's a maniac his mom is english
so he's got a little bit of a twang in
his speech
but he gets along fine with him well you
know when we did the story he really
captured the hearts of not only people
in our newsroom but our viewers so we
want to let people know that he is
available for adoption he's at the right
weight he's got a little bit of training
under his belt now what would be the
great kind of uh
home situation for zion so he would do
well he's fine with other dogs he's fine
with dogs of all sizes but the ideal
home for him as someone that's willing
to continue the training because anybody
that would adopt him
it actually comes with a year's worth of
training from myself or my wife tegan
and we
just help you maintain and make sure he
stays at the house tell us the name of
your training company it is lucky pop
dog training okay that's a really nice
value so thank you so we're going to
keep our fingers crossed if you are
interested in zion and interested in the
the training that's included you can
reach out to the vegas pet rescue
project we'll have that information for
you on our website